et décrivez-lui cette expérience.
(Rires)
C'est difficile, hein ?
Je ne m'attends pas à ce que vous le fassiez.
Vous seriez tous mal à l'aise et gênés.
Alors imaginez une fille de 11 ans au Moyen-Orient
qui n'a pas eu d'éducation sexuelle,
que l'on a arrachée de sa zone de confort,
sa famille,
qui a été témoin de l'exécution de son père et de ses frères,
devant décrire en détails
le viol qu'elle a subi dans une culture où parler de sexualité est tabou.
Sa seule façon de recouvrer son honneur est de dissimuler le crime,
de croire qu'elle a été mariée contre son gré
ou de nier les événements par honte et peur d'être rejetée.
J'ai interviewé une fille que j'appellerai Ayda.
Elle a été achetée par un dirigeant de Daech, ou émir,
avec 13 autres filles ayant entre 11 et 18 ans.
Dans le groupe, il y avait ses trois nièces et deux de ses cousines.
Les 14 filles ont été emmenées
dans une maison pleine de combattants de Daech.
Un imam était présent et a indiqué que leur religion était immorale
et que le seul chemin était d'accepter l'islam
et d'épouser un homme musulman.
L'émir a écrit le nom des filles sur 14 petits bouts de papier.
Deux combattants de Daech ont pris chacun un bout de papier.
Ils ont appelé le nom écrit sur le papier
et ces filles ont été menées de force dans une autre pièce.
Alors que l'émir et l'imam entendaient les filles crier
pendant qu'on les violait,
ils se sont mis à rire.
Ils ont dit aux autres filles
qu'elles devraient profiter de l'expérience plutôt que de crier.
Après un moment, les filles ont été ramenées dans la pièce.
Elles étaient sous le choc et elles saignaient.
Elles ont confirmé qu'elles avaient été mariées
et avaient beaucoup souffert.
Il est important de considérer le fait qu'elles avaient été élevées
pour croire au rapport sexuel avec un homme dans leur vie :
leur mari.
Le seul lien qu'elles pouvaient établir en état de choc
était de définir leur viol comme un mariage.
Avant qu'on n'emmène et ne viole les deux filles suivantes,
Ayda a pris une décision terrifiante.
En tant que l'aînée du groupe, elle a convaincu l'émir
de les laisser utiliser la salle de bains pour se laver avant le mariage.
L'une des filles avait dit à Ayda
avoir remarqué de la mort-aux-rats dans la salle de bains.
Les 14 filles ont décidé de mettre un terme à leur souffrance
en buvant le poison.
Avant que le poison ne fasse pleinement effet,
elles ont été découvertes par Daech et amenées à l'hôpital,
où elles ont survécu.
Daech a décidé de séparer les filles
et de les vendre individuellement.
Ayda a été emmenée dans une autre maison et a été brutalement violée
après avoir de nouveau essayé de se suicider avec son voile.
Elle était battue et violée tous les deux jours.
Après quatre mois en captivité,
Ayda a trouvé le courage de s'enfuir.
Elle n'a plus jamais revu les 13 autres filles.
J'ai interviewé Ayda à multiples reprises.
Elle était prête à me parler car elle avait entendu dire par d'autres victimes
qu'il y avait une femme de l'ONU qui comprenait sa culture complexe.
Je l'ai regardée dans les yeux
et j'ai écouté attentivement les histoires de ses heures les plus sombres.
Nous avons créé un lien personnel qui perdure à ce jour.
Mon éducation a rendu cela facile pour moi
de comprendre son sentiment de honte extrême
et sa peur d'être rejetée.
Ce genre d'enquêtes ne sont pas uniquement pour réunir des informations et preuves,
mais aussi pour apporter du soutien à la victime.
Les liens que j'ai créés avec les victimes
ont renforcé leur confiance en elles et leur volonté d'obtenir justice.
En envisageant de s'enfuir,
Ayda, comme toutes les survivantes yézidies,
a fait face à un dilemme :
devrait-elle continuer de souffrir de la maltraitance de ses ravisseurs
ou serait-il mieux de retourner chez elle,
où elle serait confrontée à la honte, le rejet
et possiblement un crime d'honneur ?
Je ne connaissais que trop bien la douleur du rejet
de la part de ma communauté marocaine en Belgique
et je ne voulais pas que cela arrive à la communauté yézidie.
Un groupe d'entités concernées,
comprenant l'ONU, des ONG, des politiciens et des membres de la communauté yézidie
ont abordé un dirigeant religieux,
le Baba Cheikh.
Après nombre de réunions,
il a réalisé que ces filles n'avaient pas manqué de respect envers leur religion
en étant converties de force à l'islam
et mariées à des combattants de Daech.
Elles avaient plutôt été enlevées, violées et réduites à l'esclavage sexuel.
Je suis heureuse de vous annoncer qu'après nos réunions,
le Baba Cheikh a annoncé publiquement
que les survivantes seraient traitées comme des victimes
et acceptées par la communauté.
Ce message a été entendu dans toute la communauté
et a fini par parvenir aux survivantes détenues captives par Daech.
Après sa déclaration de soutien,
les survivantes ont été motivées à fuir Daech
comme l'avait fait Ayda
et de nombreuses jeunes femmes yézidies ont agi avec courage
et sont retournées dans leurs communautés.
La déclaration publique du Baba Cheikh
a sauvé la vie de nombreuses jeunes femmes yézidies,
en captivité et après leur fuite.
Malheureusement,
tous les dirigeants religieux n'ont pas accepté de parler avec nous.
Certaines victimes ont connu un sort bien pire que celui des Yézidies.
Par exemple, seules 43 des 500 ou 600 victimes
de la communauté des Turkmènes chiites
ont pu rentrer chez elles après avoir fui Daech.
Pour certaines, leur famille leur a conseillé
de rester avec Daech
ou de se suicider afin de sauver l'honneur de la famille.
L'Allemagne a mis un projet en place pour soutenir les survivantes de Daech
en offrant un soutien psychologique et un hébergement
à 1 100 femmes et enfants,
y compris Ayda.
J'ai rendu plusieurs fois visite à Ayda avec mon travail.
Je suis si fière d'elle et des autres victimes.
Le progrès qu'elles ont réalisé est remarquable.
C'est émouvant de voir combien d'entre elles,
malgré les difficultés,
ont bénéficié de ce programme.
Le programme inclut un suivi psychologique individuel et en groupe,
de la thérapie artistique et musicale,
des activités sportives,
des cours de langues,
de l'école et d'autres efforts d'intégration.
J'ai observé qu'extraire les victimes
d'une zone de conflit vers un pays en paix
a eu un impact positif sur chacune d'entre elles.
Ce projet a attiré l'attention d'autres pays
qui ont témoigné de l'intérêt à aider plus de Yézidies.
Les femmes et filles yézidies m'appellent, m'envoient des messages
pour me parler de leurs notes à l'école,
de leurs chouettes voyages
ou pour m'informer de leurs rêves futurs,
comme écrire un livre sur ce à quoi elles ont été confrontées avec Daech.
Parfois, elles sont tristes
et ressentent le besoin de parler à nouveau des événements.
Je ne suis pas psychologue
et j'ai souffert de SSPT secondaire du fait de leurs histoires terribles.
Mais je continue de les encourager à parler
et je continue à écouter
car je ne veux pas qu'elles se sentent seules dans leur souffrance.
A travers ces anecdotes,
je vois émerger une vision globale.
Ces femmes et filles sont en voie de guérison.
Elles n'ont plus peur de réclamer justice.
Sans espoir, il ne peut pas y avoir de justice
et sans justice, il ne peut pas y avoir d'espoir.
Tous les 3 et 15 août, ce sont mes jours de commémoration
et je contacte les Yézidies
pour leur faire savoir que je pense à elles.
Elles sont heureuses quand je le fais.
C'est une journée chargée en émotions pour elles.
En août dernier, j'ai parlé avec Ayda.
Elle était heureuse d'annoncer
qu'une de ses nièces enlevée avec elle
avait enfin été libérée des mains de Daech en Syrie
et renvoyée en Irak.
Pouvez-vous y croire ?
Après quatre années ?
Aujourd'hui, son vœu le plus cher est que toute sa famille,
actuellement sur trois continents,
soit réunie.
J'espère que ce sera le cas.
En pensant aux survivantes avec lesquelles je travaille,
je me souviens des morts d'une Égyptienne médecin, écrivaine
et défenseur des droits humains,
Nawal El Saadawi.
Dans son livre, « Femme au degré zéro »,
elle a écrit : « La vie est très dure
et les seules personnes qui vivent vraiment
sont celles qui sont plus dures que la vie même. »
Ces victimes ont subi des souffrances inimaginables.
Mais avec un peu d'aide,
elles témoignent de leur résilience.
Chacune a son point de vue sur le genre de justice qu'elle recherche
et je crois profondément
qu'une procédure judiciaire crédible est essentielle
pour qu'elle recouvre sa dignité
et qu'elle close le chapitre de son traumatisme.
La justice, ce n'est pas seulement punir le coupable,
mais que la victime ait l'impression que les crimes commis envers elle
ont été documentés et reconnus par l’État de droit.
Pour moi, cela a été l'expérience d'une vie
de travailler avec ces survivantes.
Car je partage leur douleur,
leur langue et leur culture,
nous établissons des liens au plus profond de nous.
C'est en soi un acte de guérison :
être entendue, être vue,
qu'on nous offre de la compassion plutôt qu'on nous condamne.
Quand nous nous rapprochons autant de gens qui souffrent,
cela entraîne de la douleur pour les enquêteurs.
Mon travail est difficile, déchirant et traumatisant.
Mais je vais vous dire pourquoi je fais cela.
Quand je rencontre les survivantes de ces atrocités de masse,
quand je prends leur main et les regarde dans les yeux,
cela n'efface pas ma douleur,
mais elle en vaut la peine.
Il n'y a rien que je ferais plus volontiers.
Quand je vois ces courageuses survivantes
luttant pour rétablir un lien avec leur estime d'elles,
leur famille, leur place dans une société qui les estime,
c'est un honneur d'en être témoin,
c'est un privilège de chercher à obtenir justice.
C'est aussi une forme de guérison --
pour chacune d'entre nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)